hello and welcome
today we've got a very insightful talk
entitled monitoring tumor
microenvironment immunotherapeutic
impact and heterogeneous cancer prostate
cancer spatial transcriptomics and a
novel therapeutic target b7 h3 with dr
eugene chenderos assistant professor of
oncology and cancer research immunology
at johns hopkins university school of
medical medicine in baltimore maryland
i'd like to hand over the talk to dr
chandra thank you
thank you so much for the introduction
it's a pleasure to present at lab roots
and
on that note i'll take it away
these are my disclosures
today's overview of the talk will be
about prostate cancer about the role of
b7h3 potentially in prostate cancer
immunotherapy some clinical work we're
doing to try to elucidate its function
discuss how we're exploring the tumor
micro environment using the nanostring
geomets deep spatial profiler or dsp
and then just wrap everything up
together
so prostate cancer as an overview it's
the second most common cause of
cancer-related death in men
it causes approximately one in every 48
american male deaths a year
it's obviously the most common cancer in
men as well
metastatic prostate cancer has a medium
survival of five to ten years if a man
progresses to that stage
and most men
who progress that far will tend to die
of the disease
unfortunately to date the immunotherapy
revolution has really not revolutionized
prostate cancer ctla-4 or pde-1
pdl-1-axis therapies have not had
significant objective responses in
prostate cancer
even when used in combination the
results are still limited
partly this may be due to pdl1 low
expression and prostate
it could be due to other factors that
are yet unknown but overall we know that
on alternative immunological approaches
are required
in natural history of prostate cancer in
2021
starting with localized disease
is surgery and radiation for localized
disease progressing to androgen
deprivation
as one has non-castrate recurrent
disease after localized therapy if it
occurs
going on to
additional
hormonal
agents
add on to the initial entrance
deprivation therapy and then as men
progress through castrate-resistant
settings there's chemotherapy and then
there's the post-chemotherapy space and
unfortunately
after that
most men will have few treatment options
so immunotherapy is something that is
greatly needed for prostate cancer just
as it is for other cancers
we know from evidence in the field that
unfortunately the response rate to even
pembrolizumab
or pd-1 agents
in a large trial
uh presented in jcl in 2020 showed that
unfortunately for three different
cohorts of men either
men who are pdl1 positive men who are
pdl1 positive or negative with bone
disease or pdl1 negative regardless of
their pdl1 status the overall response
rate was quite low was between two to
five percent
as shown in the graph the overall
survival was
unfortunately not
significantly improved by any of the
therapy lines
for more than about
20 to 30
percent of
men over time
and
we know we can do better
the promise of immunotherapy as
highlighted in the science article
from 2013 where cancer immunotherapy was
heralded as a breakthrough which it is
for many cancer types in prostate cancer
has not yet been met today
we know that the immunological synapse
as shown here
have numerous targets some of them are
well characterized at this point with
numerous
clinical fda approvals like ctla-4 and
pd-1-axis therapies
b7h3 highlighted in the right box is a
novel target
also known as cd276 and the b7 super
family
it's also known as pdl3 compared to pdl
one and two that are well known at this
time we don't know its receptor but
there is
emerging evidence that it's got an
important role in prostate cancer
we know that there's
pretty significant expression in
prostate
in terms of mrna but even more so by
protein
of
expression
of b7h3
in the normal prostate
compared to other tissues additionally
we also know that b7h3
in prostate cancer
is one of the highest expressing cancers
so prostate cancer has a lot of b7h3 in
the tumor microenvironment
as one can see on the graph here
so potentially
that makes it and i target
explore further in prostate cancer
as shown here using two different cell
lines on the left
hbtb 119
that's known to be negative of b7h3
expression on the right gym t1 we
optimized ihc staining to show on the
right side the prostatectomy
ffpe section that benign glands in
prostate as we showed in the earlier
slides have some b7h3 expression but
tumors express tissue expresses quite a
bit of b7h3
one would call that
hot expression in a sense
so b7h3 we kind of already talked about
that it's in the b7 super family whereas
prostate cancer
or prostate expresses low amount of pdl1
b7h3 rna
is in the top one-fifth of genes
expressed b7h3 transcripts have been
shown to be operating multiple types of
tumors and again ubiquitously in
prostate cancer
multiple reports show a correlation
between b7h3 expression and adverse
pathological and clinical outcomes in
prostate cancer
and finally inhibition of b7h3
seems to limit tumor growth by enhancing
cytotoxic lymphocyte function setting it
up as a potential
checkpoint target of interest and
specifically prostate cancer in addition
to the tumor types
b7h3 protein expression is known to be
controlled by micro rna 29
there seems to be an ar binding site
upstream of b7h3 which is actually novel
for any other known potential checkpoint
targets
and also
it seems that
b7h3 expression seems to mean stable
response to hormone therapy or even
potentially increase
and finally we don't don't know the
crystal structure of human b7h3
and the receptor remains unknown so a
lot of research yet to be done on this
b7h3
seems to negatively modulate
cytotoxic t lymphocyte function
in non-small cell lung cancer and
it's responsiveness to antipedia one
therapy as shown from a recent
publication
uh by anasaka at all in 2018 and
highlighted here
furthermore recent work from
benson at all at johns hopkins in 2017
showed that on the left graph b7h3 has
significant expression
within the prostate compared to pdl one
two and four
and on top of that men who had
high b7 h3 expression had worse outcomes
in biochemical recurrence and metastatic
disease
settings which means that if one can
potentially
target b7h3 it sets it up as a
possible
checkpoint inhibitor akin to pdl1 or
ctla4
with better outcomes if one can blockade
it if
or targeted
in other means
so
we capitalized on the fact that
macrogenix a company we partnered with
to do a
investigative initiated trial
created the first in class
anti-b7h3 targeted monoclonal antibody
with optimization for adcc antibody
dependent cytotoxicity
and it's called anablatuzumab in
clinical trials shown here
where we basically used men with
who were diagnosed with prostate cancer
of intermediate to high risk stage
who received six doses of an oblitus map
in a neoadjuvant or window opportunity
setting prior to prostatectomy and then
they were followed up for up to three
years some men are still in follow-up
to try to see
whether in a bluetooth map
therapy before
radical prostectomy
decreased micrometastatic disease as
would be noted by
freedom from psa recurrence at one year
and also since this is a
early phase two trial to look at safety
and this was a very correlative rich
trial with blood and tissue collected
pre on and post treatment
and that allows us to really do a deep
dive into trying to understand b7h3
pathophysiology
and the mechanisms of response
resistance
to b7 h3 in terms of the immune tumor
microenvironment effects
what we initially noticed
is that
if one looked at pre-prostatectomy
compared to screening psa
the biochemically was the number of men
on the right side of this waterfall plot
who had psa decreases that were greater
than the red line shown which is greater
than ten percent which could be elevated
to what one would think is not what we
historically see
in such a short window of time with no
therapy normally
and so that could be indicating there's
some tumor microenvironment changes
happening from the impact of
venabletusman
very briefly
we grade prostate cancer using gleason
grading system and as shown on the left
side normal prostate cancer has intact
basal cells and intact
architecture and as you progress the
grade three four and five you lose the
architecture to more of a
sort of
non
architectured blue cell pattern
and so what we also noticed is
highlighted here is that
compared to biopsy
on prostatectomy treated patients
compared to
one-to-one match controls as shown
herein
had
quite a few
changes in terms of their gleason grade
we don't quite know what to make of this
on its own in the field there could be
changes related to just biopsy to
prostatectomy sampling
or even fixation however because we have
a control group and this seemed to be a
statistically significant change this
tells us that
possibly there is tumor microenvironment
changes occurring
from
the impact of an oblatusumab that
required further understanding
additional clinical data is still
maturing
we will continue with looking at the
tumor microenvironment
so we wanted to look at what was going
on there to explain the findings we just
showed
well we know that prostate cancer is a
very heterogeneous disease there could
be areas of normal glands interspersed
or benign interspersed with tumor
and
it makes it difficult to really
interrogate benign versus tumor as shown
here in an ffp ihc slide
there are cd8 cells highlighted and
carcinoma glands highlighted and
sometimes the cd8 may or may not be
anywhere close to a carcinoma clamp so
if one wants to for example understand
cd8
infiltration pre and post treatment one
has to also know where the carcinoma is
and where the benign areas are and what
they're comparing so tumor to tumor pre
and post
treatment for example so if one zooms in
here you can see that these are cd8 in
close association to tumor glands so
tumor infiltrating cd8
well one of the ways that
we really wanted to take advantage of
the ability to really combine
cutting-edge research in terms of the
clinic setting with cutting-edge
research in terms of
what's available
to interrogate
tissue really at the spatial level is we
partnered with nanostring in order to
utilize the deep spatial profiler to see
if we could better understand the local
tumor microenvironment between benign
and tumor areas of prostate pre-impulse
treatment
as shown here the dsp
is
a system that allows one to use imaging
reagents and profiling reagents
for both
proteome or antibody staining and as
well for transcriptome or
rna staining
and then select regions of interest in a
few different configurations which we'll
talk about china uv light onto those
regions of interest that cleaves uv
cleavable barcodes from antibodies or
probes you can aspirate those up and
basically per those regions of interest
understand what your either eye protein
expression is or rna expression is
giving a very powerful tool to really
delve into
again the tumor or the benign changes
pre and post treatment as is shown for
this trial for example
and so there are a couple of mentalities
one can choose you can choose
based on the way that equipment is set
up geometric segmentation cell type i
want to know within a region of interest
different cell types say cd8 versus
t68 or contours as shown here or
a gridded pattern
we will describe that we chose a
geometric pattern sort of looking at
tumor areas versus benign areas not
knowing what was going to be happening
with this sort of first in human study
of b7h3 targeted therapy we just wanted
to see what are the impacts that we're
seeing
between different patients and their
pre and post tissue
one can think of spatial dynamics as
they are having different cellular
compositions
and within that
the spatial distribution of how cells
are distributed compared to the tumor
can impact how those cells are
acting or not acting in terms of the
immune micro environment
so for example shown
in terms of the spatial distribution
right side figures you can have
immunosuppressive cells
you can have activated t cells but that
are excluded from the tumor
microenvironment or you can have
exhausted t cells so it's not enough to
know you have a cd8 infiltrate is that
infiltrate active is that
doesn't for example express granzyme b a
marker of activation
or are there fox p3 cells
or
also known as t reg cells that are
immunosuppressive and so
a spatial approach
to
tumor microenvironment assessment is
quite important actually the technology
itself the whole idea of spatial
transcriptomics was assigned as a
methods
uh nature methods method of the year for
2020 due to the power of what it opens
to the field as a whole
and so as shown here
this is an example of a patient's
prostatectomy tissue squares
show tumor areas and circles show benign
areas we basically
using equinimitas just highlighted
tumor areas and benign areas and tried
to stain for either cd3 or t cell cd68
or macrophages cytokeratin to identify
two more dna
and then with 40 different oligo
antibodies to try to understand protein
expression pre and post treatment
now
we can zoom into these areas
they kind of look like this so the
circle is benign on the right and then
the tumors in the box
blow up on the right as well
and we can zoom in even further and one
can see that we can see cytokeratin
cells in red and green which would be
the tumor dna
for the nucleus and cd3 in red as well
as yellow for cd68
within
very nice resolution and also down to
understanding within any region of
interest which cell types we have
and quantifying them
so this kind of just for that one sample
for example the 10 tumor areas and two
benign areas are highlighted
so what did we see well
the power of using a multeomic
technology
is the fact that again one can get
information not just about the cell type
that's infiltrating but potentially
about the activation status
or not of that cell type about
using multiplex technology like what
we're describing with a 48 plex panel
additional cell types saving tissue of
course from doing singleplex ig things
and saving time with being able to do
multiplex now there are other
technologies that you can one can do
multiplexed immunofluorescence in this
case we have four guiding
immunofluorescent probes
there are technology that can go up to
nine to ten
or even more one has to deconvolute the
signal and again once you go above a
certain number it becomes very hard in
this case you can go to 40 plex since it
uses barcodes
that really
gives
quite a bit of power
and again for the purpose of this talk
the technology that we chose to use
so
what's shown here is that pre and
oblitus map or biopsies compared to
post-inability remember the
prostatectomies on this trial there was
even after accounting for
multiple comparisons
quite significant p values in terms of
the cd8 infiltration
this cd8 cells appeared to have
granzyme b activation i will caution
that because one's looking at the entire
tumor
microenvironment within a region of
interest we don't know that the granzyme
b is tied into the cd8 it could be other
cell types like the cd68 or any other
activated
myeloid of t cells in the region but we
also saw then that the gram b increased
so there was some increase in activation
of certain immune cells in that same
area pdl1 increased and pd1 increased
which will indicate some degree of
interferon gamma
mediated activation or kind of the tumor
turning a little bit warmer or hotter
colloquially speaking in terms of the
activation status which is interesting
and so to go in a bit further
we wanted to know for example is that
cd8
noted increase
potentially an artifact or is it related
to specifically the
fact that we actually see a cd
infiltration as an example of one of the
markers and so using gold standard
singleplex ihc shown on the left versus
the nanostring cd8
for a
subset of patients 13 of the initial 32
patients on the trial that were accrued
we showed that basically
compared to untreated controls
versus treated in terms of
untreated are black
and green dots are they treated we see
almost a
very similar distribution between
singleplex ihcd8 and cd8 nanostring
based quantification which gives us a
high degree
of confidence that the findings we're
seeing
on the dsp
are what's actually occurring in the
tune microenvironment
now we did mention that we use the 40
plex panel which means that we also have
a way to
look at more markers simultaneously than
just cd8 or just for anti-v and so here
showing a volcano plot
which shows
fold change
on the x-axis so towards the right is
increased expression in prostatectomy
samples
versus on the left increased expression
in the biopsy pre-treatment samples
and
on the y-axis vp value one can see that
quite a few of the markers and this is
not
uh unexpected are increased
this is a 40 plex panel chosen for
proteins related to
immune activation and since we see a bit
of immune activation they're kind of
all skewed towards the right
some of the dots obviously are not
significant and show them gray some of
the dots are statistically significant
after adjustment for
mixed model
analysis
and are shown in
light blue and then if the fold changes
over two-fold
on the x-axis then they're also shown
and statistically significant they're
shown in a darker color and so one can
see that there is upregulation of
what appears to be granzyme b
as well as
some other marker c45 c163 fox b3
which
and then of course there's things that
have a lower fall change but are still
statistically significant
which tells us possibly some or all of
those are truly up regulated to a
biologically
important degree
and one can also see for example pd1
is not meeting the full change greater
than two
criteria but it is
highly statistically significant so it's
telling us there is some degree of
t cell and what appears to be myeloid
immune activation within the tumor mark
environment
which again with the first and class
agent is interesting and something that
we're putting together further for
publication in the near future
telling us that there is definitely
something going on post this treatment
with this antibody optimized for
adcc now we have no idea if the antibody
itself is blocking or not because as
highlighted at the beginning of the
introduction we don't know what the
receptor is for b7h3 and we can't do
blocking studies
in that regard or occupancy studies
for blocking
purposes
using the nanostring
i o 360 panel to look at
rna expression
and in this case between
one-to-one match controls or untreated
prostatectomy patients
versus the treated prostatectomies from
treated men
compared to the previous volcano plot
which was
longitudinal pre-treatment biopsies to
post-treatment prostatectomies within
the same
individual comparison
here we see that between treated and
untreated controls
again there is a capitulation of
immune changes indicating higher and
treated
of various immune functions
like il-18 hla-dr
indicating some presentation changes
lysozyme 96
and so
indicating again that there's some
degree of myeloid
activation potentially
consistent direction changes between the
two different analyses again a
significant additional amount of work is
ongoing
but as highlighted here
quite interesting preliminary tumor
microenvironment signals showing some
degree of tme impact from the
drug so in conclusion for this brief
talk b7 h3 a place to play an important
yet undefined role in prostate cancer
neoadjuvant b7h3 monoclonal targeted
therapy appears to be feasible we didn't
go into the safety but it was a
relatively well tolerated drug for this
trial demonstrated
essential efficacy and prostate cancer
again we didn't go too much into the
overall efficacy we talked about the
pre-treatment um
to
immediately prior to prosthetic psa
changes and also a little bit of the
gleason changes from pre-spot treatment
biopsies to prostatectomies
but there's a lot more work that needs
to be done in terms of identifying the
receptor for b7h3
metastatic b7h3 targeted antibody drug
therapy is being studied as well
and
spatial proteomics and transcriptomics
is driving insights into b7h3 murals as
highlighted herein
with preliminary data indicating that
there is a robust intra-tumor induction
or adaptive upregulation of immune
checkpoints potentially t cell
activation and potentially myeloid
inflammation
more needs to be understood again
for example even for the myeloid
inflammation whether that's beneficial
myeloid inflammation or some degree of
adaptive myeloid inflammation to the t
cell activation
again more work in this space
is ongoing
on that note
work like this first and foremost occurs
thanks to the patients who give us the
opportunity to try to treat them with
the next generation therapies that can
hopefully meaningfully impact their
disease so to all the patients on the
clinical trials with a serious
appreciation for their participation
thank you and then additionally
to numerous collaborators and colleagues
from
nanostring macrogenix who provided the
drug
my own lab group our biostatistician
clinical trial team members our gu
department of course
the
pathologists
and the funding sources who make all
this possible on that note i'm happy to
take any questions
it's a pleasure to be here and to talk
with all of you thank you
[Music]
thank you dr chandra that was an
interesting presentation on the tumor
and tumor microenvironment in prostate
cancer
we do have a couple of questions
first you showed preliminary data for
the tumor microenvironment have you been
able to use spatial transcriptomics to
assess what happens in the benign
prostate compartment
of the b7 h3
treated patients
that's a very good question
as we alluded to
we are looking at both the tumor and the
benign compartment
we are still in the process of
fully
understanding that data and there is
more that we will
present
hopefully in the manuscript and
potentially upcoming meetings in the
near future so
stay tuned
exciting
um and another question
what is the main utility you see for
spatial proteomics and transcriptomics
going forward
i think that and that's again another
insightful question
the benefit of technology like this
beyond even what's highlighted here
um
stems from the fact that it can really
operate on quite small amounts of tissue
where before if one wanted
wanted to do potentially
bulk
rna-seq or bulk
numbers i would say
as we showed here 40 plex ihc
if one uses
sort of standard ihc or any bulk
techniques that requires a bit of tissue
and for a lot of clinical applications
and different tumor types like for
example for metastatic
prostate cancer patients when we get
biopsies we get very little
uh sometimes
tissue that's left over beyond any
clinical use
that's used for that's useful for
research purposes
and technology like this really allows
us to potentially interrogate
the changes
in those small amounts of tissue for
multiplex iit applications as shown here
or for
transcriptome applications as described
beyond what one could do with just a
standard single or
ffp slide or two or three fp slides
so that's one it's opening
the ability to do more work with less
specimen in the clinical arena which we
know is incredibly important for really
advancing and understanding
therapeutics especially immune-based
therapeutics in the body
in the translational clinical setting
and then finally additionally given the
power of the technology in terms of
just
spatially localizing
what is going on
between benign tumor areas is
highlighted and
other combinations of ways
this opens a new area where combining
single cell
with spatial transcriptomic features it
really will help the field dig into
trying to understand
what's going on between cell types and
where they're specifically located
spatially in regards to the
tumor benign
etc
localized microenvironment and i think
that will be
an incredible
uh resource for the scientific community
going forward to use the spatial
transcriptomic spatial proteomics
approaches to get that additional
insight
that was fantastic thank you very much
uh for the answer um i'd like to thank
you dr shandera for your presentation
and this will conclude our session today
thank you all for attending